congratulations cardell how you feeling
pretty good now I'm sorry get up a
buffalo it's worse where are you new
time I'm back still home at the Columbus
Ohio I see you know I'm coming Buffalo
thursday i love the video where you well
describe it if somebody didn't see the
video when your name was announced that
you were going to buffalo how would you
describe what happened right after that
unbelievable it was a build up and allow
emotions pouring out all at one time
well then you ripped off your your shirt
your tank town yeah that was the motion
in the Builder that was that was for the
build of the last three days well you're
not going to do a tank top in Buffalo
though cardell so you're gonna need all
the warm clothing you think it's been
cold in Columbus you're gonna need a
whole lot more than that in Buffalo I
know what doing wilco what I'm pretty
sure if not my issue growing up an
equivalent in plants like two hours down
south to Columbus but pretty sure I
haven't experienced a cold like in
Buffalo property ready for where did you
think you were going um I had no clue
but uh coach Ryan also you letting me
know that um if I was available when
they had a cupcake that he was gonna
grab me how what did you talk about with
coach run after he drafted you I'm just
being excited about the opportunity he's
been able to get in there and I'm aha uh
two great guys and one day hopefully
have a chance at the people starting job
um you know you have basically embracing
me and you know everything to come for
me how much thought did you give have
you given to had you come out after
winning the national title as opposed to
what played out this year being drafted
in the fourth round no no I mean I
thought was cool AHA me when I decided
to make the decision to return back to
school so I never had any second you
guys
or regrets about returning back OSU last
year it's tough to do though yeah I once
you made that decision you never allowed
yourself to second-guess your decision
right right and I wanted to make sure I
was all there for you know for my
potentially my final season at LSU
instead of no living with her regresa
what could have been what did you learn
this season at Ohio State a lot um
really a lot more about myself and
really being a player you know there
were like I versity I'm overcame a lot
deal with a lot far as what how do know
play the position of the court of vacuum
really dissect the game and understand
you know that's what a face or a leader
your your temple your heart be at office
what did you make when coach said and
I'm paraphrasing about you not being a
great student but you know as far as
school work but you know football-wise
it was different so I I don't know how
you took that in what he was saying
about you oh hey whatever he said he
said it up I really not gonna get too
much depth into that you know what that
person with us where I am and a good
thing about that and that's not matter
anymore so I'm just looking forward to
the opportunity I have now are you going
to be competing for the starting job
were you told that no I wasn't telling I
wasn't promising thing only thing I was
probably get in and I'll work your butt
off an iron your spine York you know
basically yeah your role on the team
well congrats and good luck in Buffalo
and dress warm Carnell even in the
summer I sure will alright thanks for
joining us it's a Cardale Jones Bills
quarterback the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience